today we're gonna be talking about a
player that I personally have a
tremendous amount of respect for I've
also heard Boris Gelfand say that this
is his favorite player so Boris Gelfand
is one of the top players in the world a
couple years ago play for a world
championship so if he's if he's his
favorite player I'm sure you know he's
got some impressive things to show us so
I'm talking today about Akiba Rubinstein
does anybody has anybody ever heard of
him good pretty much all the hands are
up excellent
let's see so he's made a lot of
different types of contributions he's
affected almost every opening out there
or at least many many different types of
openings he also was an endgame virtuoso
and one of the games we'll see you today
was an incredible attacking game where
he pretty much has blew his opponent off
the board so I'm just gonna see if I
raise a hand if I raise the hands if any
of you have played some of his openings
so he has created he created an opening
variation in the nimzo-indian defense
after this does anyone play the
nimzo-indian defense all right good so
somebody raised their hand perfect
so somebody probably has already seen
this he also created a famous variation
named after him in the French defense
so has anyone ever played this position
before very much I really
so his variation was D take C for here
usually white responds with capturing
the night and it's a bit of a dry
variation usually it has a tendency to
be a bit dull but nevertheless people
are still playing to stay there is a
famous German Grandmaster named George
Meier who still basically plays this
religiously with black and he has good
results drawing a couple world champions
with it with it like I think Anand
recently so definitely not a bad opening
he has a variation of the Queens gambit
declined named after him
does anyone play that one so all of
these openings I mean a very mainstream
and his contributions are very very
important so he had his variation is
named just the Rubinstein variation and
it continues after these moves
so even today people still they'll still
play this and it's considered a very
very good line for white to try to
achieve an opening advantage I should
also add that the variation the
nimzo-indian that he created it was the
main line for overall for almost 100
years so it's not like his his opening
variations that he's creating are just
very like sideline oriented and to me
something like the alekhine defense
which was named after a world champion
that's a bit more offbeat and not many
people play it but these are openings
that are still relevant today and may as
mainstream as it gets he also has a
variation in the tirage defense named
after him which is still the main line
today also
so the trois usually begins with these
moves and his setup was consisting of an
early king-size bean kettle which at the
time was pretty much revolutionary
almost no one was considering to play it
this way sorry so he would play g3
Bishop g2 and Castle quickly take on c5
potentially try to exploit the weak D
pawn and you know it was the first one
to create this idea so still people are
still playing this almost religiously
with with white against the tirage
defense so these are just to name a few
I did actually find out that there is a
trap that he would blunder it in through
twice that was named after him so this
is kind of a dubious honor but it would
continue like like this and he's such a
great player I would have a hard time
imagine imagining someone falling into
it once but twice is just incredible
there's more than one way to reach this
there's different mu borders but
apparently through a Rubinstein did it
matter so he plundered twice like this
let's see if you guys can figure it out
last time it was a terrible mistake yeah
why is this terrible what has a strong
move yeah bingo
so Knight takes d5 is a very powerful
capture an immediately threatens Bishop
c7 trapping the Queen it has the point
that if pawn captures knight the bishop
comes to c7 and blacks queen is trapped
so you know black would be just
worsening the troubles at this point and
even on d5 it's doing something useful
over over protecting the bishop on f4 so
that even if black plays the the best
move Knight takes f4 you don't have to
damage your Pollock sure you can capture
the knight everything's fine the healthy
extra pollen a strong center and whites
off to a great start
so yeah still still amazed that he felt
that that one twice the last thing that
I can remember the last contribution
that that jumps out at me as being very
important is a opening variation in the
four Knights defense so that starts out
like this and the main line continues
with Bishop e5 and there is several ways
that black and try to continue Bishop e4
is a popular popular move Bishop c5 is
another reasonable move even Bishop d6
looks kind of strange but this is a
decent move to with planning castling
well let's make some moves so Bishop
sorry castle castle I'll say with you
one rook e8 and then we see the point
that black wants to try to retreat the
bishop to f8 then they can move the D
pawn and they've managed to sort of
develop their pieces without actually
have a having obstructed themselves so
they would reach a reasonable is a
position like that the way he would
choose to play it though would be like
this and this is actually a very
aggressive move I was doing a little
research and saw that there's actually
been some games played where
after a knight takes e5 here which looks
like a critical response trying to just
capture that unprotected pawn blacks
black has a good idea in playing Queen
e7 so the main reason to do this is that
if we try to switch the move order and
take first we are constantly dealing
with problems with the C seventh one so
we try committee seven now we have the
obvious issue of this fork so after the
might check blacks just in big trouble
so it makes sense to play Queen e7 first
f4 kind of a weird looking position
sorry take take and then d6 the knight
has to move now black takes with the
Queen and everything looks looks fine
although after king f2 need to just make
sure I'm a I'm a double check that this
is correct I'll come back to later but
at least I believe the craziness to kind
of start from this point where white
bring us is king out to g3 and there I
believe there have been some games I'll
double-check this just to make sure but
you know clearly if this this is off to
a very very wild start
all right so I believe those are those
are most of the opening contributions
that he's he's kind of shown us a lot of
them still relevant today and now we're
gonna look at probably his most famous
game and maybe one of the most famous
games ever played so his opponent was
someone named rot Louie a good chess
player at the time and he starts out
with the black pieces so due to the fact
that I have a couple of games that I'd
like to show I may go through this this
game a little bit quicker even though
there's actually a lot of interesting
points with a lot of crazy attacking
combinations and it deserves a lot
longer than I'll give it but we got to
get through it a little bit quicker okay
so start it through this move will move
order so basically this is a tirage
defense just mirrored and symmetrical
and an opening that doesn't really have
the best reputation for giving Y a
advantage but you know still reasonable
so I'll start commenting once the kind
of important points start popping up so
up until then both sides are just
continue with logical developing moose
okay can can you tell me why this pawn
is not actually able to be captured I'm
sure you can what would happen if you go
here let's hear from someone else yep
perfect so anytime there's two pieces
x-raying each other like this if you
move the one in between with check a lot
of times it's going to leave the the
piece opposite you're a heavy piece
available for capture so your take the
queen is gonna be left unprotected no
matter what no matter what black sari no
matter what weight plays even if they
retreat the bishop will just take okay
so I continue with Bishop e2
still not threatening to take the pawn
on d5
so black castles 22 this move got
criticized I think a lot after the game
because it turned out to be a little bit
slow the queen is not very well placed
here and I think it needed to be moved
once spending another temple later on
the game as well so black played Queen
e7 this is a wise move one idea that you
may want to consider when you're playing
these Queen's Gambit type of positions
with the pawn on c4 is that if you're
playing black you usually want to wait
until they move their f1 Bishop so you
can capture on c4 and force em to to
waste a turn before playing mu that
usually want to play so in the game you
play Bishop b3 and then Rubenstein
showed this idea yeah
good question I don't see an immediate
tactical reputation but I think you're
right that black is kind of getting
overwhelming activity let's see you so
rook da might be a good way to start
introducing threats again to take so you
know it doesn't turn out well anyway for
white but not sure that's gonna help but
just opening wise let's say you you play
some of these Queen's Gambit positions
it's useful to wait until this bishop
moves before taking so white is forced
to spend an extra move moving the bishop
place all right so now black plays b5
and it's kind of foreshadowing now the
bishop is going to come to the b7 square
and the the powerful bishops which are
going to be aimed towards the King are
eventually what deliver the the crushing
final final attack in the game white
plays Bishop t2 48 and that is an
additional move the Queen e2 so he's
actually been forced to waste two moves
already so he played Bishop e3 white
black took on c4 forcing white to waste
the move with the bishop now the Queen
that moved to d2 spent a second turn
going to eat you so white started out on
the on the positive side of the
symmetrical opening opening moves but
now he's actually behind and Rubenstein
shows an excellent way to take advantage
of this lead in development at he has so
he he just makes natural moves until
there's a reason not to or let's say a
reason to keep to improve the pieces
once they've reached their best
positions so he can white castles now
you play is 95 so he's clearing the
pathway for the Bishop attacking the
knight on f3 if you know if why it's
very cooperative they might let you take
and double the pollen from the king but
of course you can't assume that they're
gonna do it but even if even if white
doesn't
after this black's pieces are just full
just coming
totally to life and notice that they're
the bishops are just bearing down on the
King already so I plays f4 if you're
retreats well it's not quite caught up
in development so this whole rolling the
pawns and trying to be a little bit
aggressive is maybe not the best
strategy here he's behind a development
usually attacking ideas don't work in
those situations so Rubinstein takes the
opportunity to just finish developing
now all this pieces are in play after E
5 now he really shows where his strong
chess ability comes into play so he
starts with Bishop e6 a good move
forcing the King to the corner and now
I'm gonna ask you guys to try to figure
out what black should do so I bet some
of you might have already seen this game
but you know try not to spoil it if you
if you do know the answer
I see something ugly out there and it's
like teen talking okay got it
raise our hand if you know the answer
okay
so someone that doesn't know the answer
take a shot at it what would you do 94
okay so do you care that it's
unprotected there okay so if if 94 and I
take it then you pull your work tasty 3
that's what you're saying
perfect yep okay you having a different
idea huh
okay good question it's always worth
thinking about whether you can just
desperado your piece and if it's gonna
be captured you might as well get rid of
it while taking something here though
black is actually still going to use
this rope powerfully and generate some
strong strong threats so rook d2 is a
very very strong hitting to beat the b2
bishop and threatening to take the pawn
on g2 so we got the that bishop just
bearing down on g2 and in combination
with Roarke it's just unstoppable
so why it's gonna lose a lot of material
here so taking on a chef doesn't does it
doesn't quite work out so why tries to
make the most of it and you know maybe
it's it's just a variation like this
that he was analyzing during the game
that we just that we just took at took a
look at over the board that kind of
indicated how strong that LightSquared
bishop was so his next move was aiming
to trade off one of blacks best
attackers which makes perfect sense
didn't quite get the job done though so
let's see why what would you do here
with with black you've got this this
nice lead-in development how could you
keep creating threats
there we go we niche for it's like
really like one-track mind but that's
the object of the game so why is little
considerate yeah it's a great great move
so clearly the threat is Queen Queen
takes h2 so who cares about the bishop
on p7 right now yeah
okay is this just like inspiration right
now or did you see this okay now I
understand all right
rook takes c3 so this this is just one
of the most spectacular moves that I
think it almost has ever been played but
yeah so if you just found this right now
you know I don't know if you would have
tackled everything but good move now it
is better okay let me just ask you I
want to like make double check you know
everything until the end of game just to
make sure you didn't just like randomly
give your give me your queen so if I
take your queen what you gonna do
okay there is there are some problems
with that yeah like we taste meat AC -
yeah okay yeah now we're getting is like
the meat of the game there's all sorts
of threatening moves you can play D -
okay so Bishop takes e 2 and then rookie
- Bishop takes you for sorry that's what
got it this is you can't just give away
your Queen and then figure it out later
you gotta you gotta calculate this out
first something like why are you gonna
move like yeah like a white like a white
year or something
rookie - okay all the other moves are
worth considering but unfortunately one
of the problems when you when you've
already sacrifice a lot of material
you're trying to attack is that you need
to just be alert for your opponent
giving back material to get rid of your
attackers so that's one of the problems
with a lot of these moves
for example yeah for example I gots a
rookie three this is very threatening
move but why it's already up a queen for
a night right now so they don't need to
keep all of that material in order to
have a winning position so I would
probably just sacrifice the Queen to try
to just eliminate as many attackers as
possible right now if white were to play
a cooperative move like moving the Queen
somewhere then your idea it makes
perfect sense but you know be alert for
your opponent giving back the actual
material and just you know taking taking
less but still enough so let's say you
take I'll get the bishop afterwards and
even if white only emerges with an extra
piece black is reduced to almost no
attacking chances at this point and why
should win so that was one of the one of
the problems and just a variation kind
of illustrates an important idea about
attacking chess
if you play Bishop takes e4 and then try
Ricky - it looks threatening Queen a it
looks like a like a problem there you go
you could walk with a bishop but I can
take this rook and there's no longer
made on h2 the bishops not on b6
covering the square so yep why it's
completely waning unfortunately up a lot
of material threatening mate on d8 so
can't can't play all these moves so
somehow you figure out route D to my
shop so I don't even thing I would
figure out these moves it's like so
complicated Ricky - it's not even like
the most obvious attacking move it's
just kind of almost like a quiet move
just no immediate threat of checkmate or
anything like that just disappointing
all always pieces yeah you're throwing
in 20 nuts true but okay there's no
there's no mate that's what you're
already down to Queens ooh if you if you
threaten only a queen where you say one
more time
that is true so take on e4 is actually
the biggest threat so a good point so
white acts responds to that question by
you know the most obvious answer
taking the rook kind of asking what
blacks plan was that is that is correct
so Queen eg2 you need to interpose with
something because the these two bishops
they're the monsters just controlling
all of those squares towards the king so
you could theoretically just throw the
rook it in in between you know to waste
some time maybe but this is just gonna
this is basically just admitting defeat
so black will take you still have to
walk with the Queen you've lost so look
for almost no reason if if black wants
they can take rook c2 and they're
emerging with a lot of extra material
here so that's pretty much unplayable
there may be other problems as well so
it takes Queen Chi to somebody else
yeah okay if rooks see you know I think
we're c2 works
it wasn't what was playing the game
though you know night-night f2 well I
gave it away yeah sorry so Rick c2 it
makes sense to try to protect the Queen
obviously
so let's say which one is a potential
way to do it but the Queen can't move so
some other me and the main issue is that
after taking compared to the variation
with the Queen was on eight and the
bishop was blocking the check now the
bishop controls the G 1 square so struck
me so I think this is a very effective
way just as effective as the game yeah
so Rick h3 I don't know how did you
figure out all these moves so I got I'm
usually like a trusting person but
something is not right
you've never seen this and just play
like all these spectacular moves with no
calculation all right I'll take I'll
take your word for right now at least
attacking h2 threatening me that's right
like it like it's so simple so we're
going to you know it we're gonna tool it
will keep the game going but there's so
many pins here takes yeah you can even
just take this is still pinned the
bishop pins the Rick to the king oh
that's just is it me you mean - oh yeah
saying Bishop here yeah let me try this
one I mean I'm not saying this is good
but theoretically I can play on okay no
I can't play on you're right
good good point all right you're looking
look at these moves better than I am
okay so alright that would be an
effective way to finish the game mate
would be delivered all right so in this
game I think white had enough he
resigned I don't you guys kind of
demonstrated it's probably forced mate I
didn't double-check it but you know why
it's why it's hopeless here so that's
that's a game that guy showed almost
everywhere like every chess club that's
probably shown this game at least a
couple times and you know to me like the
lasting images those bishops just kind
of bearing down on the king and for
other reasons why the the more highly
rated you get like you just fall in love
with the bishop combo so I'm gonna move
on to a new game
unfortunately not every game is as
spectacular spectacular as this one so
actually although I just showed you an
extremely attacking oriented game one of
the most fun games alar see Reubens I
was definitely not known to be like a
middle game wizard just throwing his
pieces around at people trying to
checkmate
he's actually like very methodical and
positionally oriented player and he
would actually you know just best known
for grinding people down and winning in
the endgame so this is a good example
he's playing against a very strong
opponent actually the world champion at
the time Emanuele asked her and one
thing I'd like to add also is that at
one point Rubinstein was considered to
be I think the strongest player in the
world the only problem was he had a
world championship match that he had all
scheduled to play but then world war ii
world war 1 broke out and that kind of
put an end to things there's no world
champion match at that point and then
once the war ended he was just not quite
the same player so he kind of
unfortunately just for timing reasons
never really got the chance he deserved
to play for the world champ would have
been a you know an interesting match so
he's playing white in this game so
Alaska is black
I'm gonna go through through these moves
quickly once again actually this opening
is not really regarded with a good
reputation for black when when white can
can give whites I'm sorry when white can
give black a isolated pawn on d5
while having such active pieces that
easily pressure the d5 pawn usually this
is a sign that white is too strong a
pressure for black to justify giving
themselves a weakness like an isolate
upon a d5 so this is actually not
opening that black wants to play but in
those days the opening variations were
not as well known
so we're gonna get to the some of the
important points in the middle game
quickly okay we're coming up to a key
position so white is made it through the
opening up upon blacks got up strong
bishop on cu6 but it doesn't quite
justify being down upon yes good
question
all right so this is definitely a
threatening looking move I'm wondering
if I go here how you plan on responding
okay that's what I was expecting
so yeah Ricky let's try Ricky eight the
Queen should block if you try King f1
the only other opportunity that's a very
good question though so if you play
Queen e2 not really the best result for
white
the knight is likely to be trapped on a
even a move like b6 right away is
probably just gonna capture the knight
immediately but maybe black can get
greedy and playing with like Queen takes
g2 and try to gather some extra material
first Queen g4 is yeah there's just tons
of good continuations for for black here
so yeah why it's just losing pretty much
everything so why do you three good good
move
all right so this is actually the key
point the game so Black has just played
this the sacrifice where it takes III
and although it's basically giving away
the rook you know why can't capture
right away because this would just be
checkmate
so white needs to give away in the rook
first removing the threatening piece
combining on g2 with the Queen black
takes and it looks like like black is
getting out of danger here actually
because you know the the normal move
would be to take take the rook Black's
gonna gonna capture the pawn restore the
material balance and even d4 is
unprotected afterwards so black chances
definitely wouldn't be worse here it's
I'm not gonna say that black is
definitely better but you know the tide
is turning
alright so has anyone seen this game too
all right
okay so everyone except you
you can answer this question what what
you might do it's funny because he
actually plays the same exact move and
it's like spectacular for different
reasons and in another game against the
world champion which and his opponent
and the other game was Capablanca yes
Queen c1 you you are already cheering I
name is say was right but yeah that's
movie so queen c1 excellent and why
makes several threats here he's
threatening the c6 pawn although maybe
that's not the most important threat now
there's the pin with the with the
roofing between the two queens and you
know the black the black can't go
anywhere safely in order to break the
pin end let's say capture back the Queen
so move like this would be in theory is
something that you could try but already
taking taking the rook so White's left
in the winning position so that's
definitely not option rookie five would
be another way you could try something
like this but you take on c6 again take
the rook oops
all right so black is in trouble here in
this queen c1 it was kind of shocking
moved a lot of people and ironically he
had the same type of strong tactic and
it's using the same exact move just in a
in a different situation but against
another world champion
so black took and eventually we're gonna
get to a situation where white
Rubinstein got to show off you know his
his his strength that most people know
him for which is his end game play and
he he was considered by a lot of people
to be the route the best work end game
player we're gonna go to a nice Rick end
game where he eventually causes black to
resign with this quiet little move that
you know you wouldn't even expect so
rook d7 take this is actually a really
strong move as well so there's a few few
reasons to play this move why do you
think white play this move yes
sure yeah Cardinal sure
okay so what do you think it's wise main
idea for just protecting the pond or
isn't another idea he's combining okay
so it sounds like right now Queen takes
c3 is the main priority for this move
which it is but there is another reason
why he played it was there another
remove that you wanted to to say or no
okay great
so you definitely recognize the key
point there's a secondary idea which is
to play Queen eight check and then once
the King goes to e7 now the work can
actually be used aggressively on the
fourth-ranked and white can play a keep
Ricky for lure the King out a little bit
farther maybe try to try to cause some
some damage to blacks to blacks King
what about this move like this looks a
little scary huh how is why can't avoid
trouble here I wouldn't play this that's
for sure so yeah it's nice when you have
only like one reason we'll move it makes
it easy but okay now let's say I try
this it's like you only have one
reasonable move again so as I'm asking
these questions but really there's only
one answer
yeah hang out three that's not the
reasonable answer if you go here
all right so that's a problem actually
you may even be able to get it get away
with both of these moves don't remember
which one is actually the strongest here
it looks to me like he one should do the
trick though so my my idea would be that
now I want to attack this this rope that
way you still come you still have your
existing threats with Queen a8 you can
play maybe rook to you for now the check
and if black tries to play Queen takes
g2 which looks like a pretty reasonable
kind of counter attacking move yeah
wrote d4 is a really strong move so if
you can get black to take and now the
Queen is unprotected so you can just
snap the Queen off with your queen
there's no good way to block King has
only one move and after this very good
so the King's got to move there you go
so all all blues are good checkmate is
the best
so after this King e8 Queen Queen D is
coming and game over
so this Queen takes tree to looks look
looks like mov you you definitely need
to have a response for but it just
doesn't cut it
alright so black tries f5 in the game
well he plays queen c5 so he's
threatening Queen f8 then he may capture
the pawn on f5 black wants to avoid all
these threatening threatening options
with whites Queen so they go into an
endgame here alright so how would you
continue here
can't tube so the only other option is
work f1 why would you
fantastic that's pretty much perfect so
the it's it's tempting to play recap one
because it looks like you're gonna keep
your troop on advantage but after up d2
yeah one of the most important things
about working on games is that you you
really want to try to make sure all your
pieces are active because well
especially have two passive pieces like
it may turn out here I'll give you if
you have to play a move like repeat one
your rook is it's not perfect
well I can always win this epon with
something like rookie two but more
importantly the King is kind of cut out
of play and just activity of blacks
pieces now are it's gonna reduce White's
winning chances rook F 2 is also a move
that might jump out to some people after
after if D with D 2 but after we get to
yeah the bet the best way to I can do is
repeat for the moment so after rook d2
once again now way it's gonna have to
choose something else so probably what
you want in just hope that your your
pawn advantage will eventually win but
blacks defensive chances will be better
than before
all right so King F 2 was playing the
game good move D 2 can have three so one
thing that you can learn if you if you
end up studying the endgame is
Rubenstein or pretty much any other good
player so they usually value activity
and endgame very very highly so right
now there you can notice there's a
dramatic difference between the King on
g1 in and on f3 so on f3 that the king
is ready to sport pawns being pushed
it's coupled together very nicely with
the palm and III if you know white wants
to advance this passed pawn and now we
can actually see that after the idea
that you mentioned Rick a5 once black
plays rook b7 trying to defend
everything white is up a pawn has the
more active pieces and can kind of use
the more active pieces now to just
slowly improve his position and because
black has almost no active plan
you can you can take your time to just
nurse your position and make all the
improvements you want before you try to
change the nature of the position maybe
with creating a different type of past
pawn or making some exchanges before
that point you can you can take all the
time you want because black has no
active plan mm-hmm okay excellent
rook a six so now we're gonna restrict
blacks pieces even more so it's tempting
to to improve the King but there's no no
need to allow blacks King any extra
opportunities to get to the fourth rank
all right third rank I guess third rank
for black six rank for white so why I
can play King F for any time but after
okay six blacks options are more limited
okay so now we'll just see that white
sorry black ends up just shuffling
around and not able to do anything
active with this rook because it needs
to protect this weak pawn on a seven the
King can't pass up the board to blockade
White's pass pawn so black is basically
just stuck and now white just slowly
improves starts with E for so this is a
nice move avoiding checks so that now
White's King will have shelter black
tried rook c7 in the game but most moves
are just going to matter the same thing
so any other move along a sample most
likely just reach the same type of
result so now you know what's just
improving all this all this pieces even
though even the policy an improvement so
no need to leave them on the second rank
where they could be attacked by the rook
once the King advances now they're gonna
be advanced maybe they can eventually be
pushed far enough so that they can
restrict the black King which is going
to be shuffling around those squares so
let's say you get a pawn to g6 at some
point if you can capture back with your
H pawn that would be a potentially very
strong idea limiting blacks options even
further but you know as the pawns
advance the King is going to be
advancing with them and supporting the e
pawn so all wise pieces will be court
coordinated and good winning chances
king f7 have eight
so what black is just going back and
forth absolutely no active plan so once
you see your opponent doing this you
know just dream up the ideal position
for your pieces put them all there and
try to only change the position once
once they're all ready so now black
please h6 you may have been looking to
prevent g5 where White's likely to play
g6 and black is losing a lot of squares
on the seventh rank and whites King is
gonna have a basic anywhere he wants to
go whoops so he plays h6 hanging out
five you have seven so now basically
white has improved as position as as
much as possible
black has no active plans still okay
work do six
so they repeat one time sure yeah I
think that actually Rubenstein might
have been trying to reach reach a time
control because his he ends up repeating
and there's no obvious reason why to me
at least but that's the Feingold rule so
actually even after repeating white
black chooses to play King f8 no joke
it's possible also that after king e7
maybe white was waiting till he had more
more time in the clock before making
committal choice like playing something
like retreat 6 king f7 and pushing pawn
up at least if something like this were
to happen the the rook is losing some of
its activity oh yeah
so q6 also a good idea so yeah it's
likely that this is going to reach a
position so much like game 2 so probably
over here
hmm maybe this is good too I tried to
shuffle around I think should be nice
yeah what idea you might actually
consider would be let's say he tries the
yeah yeah this doesn't work can also
take take here so everything is
protected so it helps to have these
pawns improved on g4 and h5 now
everything is a little bit easier to be
supported and they're ready to be pushed
so King f8 no draw and after rooks e6 I
think black actually resigns after their
White's next move
so in this position black is actually in
Zeus long so if the rook moves at d7 u6
can be played winning the rook after
this you six can still be played the
King's got to retreat to eat it loses
the game instantly so just showing that
for demonstrative purposes King f8
forces a rook exchange after rook c8 so
that's not a good idea when you're gonna
lose the king of potting game King g8
extremely passive this looks really
strong King is forced to go to h7 where
it's basically no longer participating
at all wait it has a couple ways to win
this endgame you could just shuffle the
King around to d6 push the pawn probably
other ways to but once the king is on
each sevenths not very good so that's
one move but any other room for for
black let's say moving the rook off of
the off of the seventh rank is just
going to cause white to play roof c7 and
take on a seven something like this
why I was able to get another pawn
I can't really think of any other decent
attempts for black here
how can you see any other options to sum
it all up it is bad so that's pretty
much pretty much the end of this end
game and so I might just like to show
you the one other the one of the game
really quickly not the whole thing but
just the position where Queen c1 turns
out to be a very strong move so you can
see that now that black resigned because
he was losing extra material here and
there's there's really no good way to
continue this
wait sorry yeah let me get to the
position really quick so there we go
he's playing his Tosh variation so now
once again he like completely shocked
his opponent with this strong Quincy one
move so in this position last got the
threat to the knight which looks like no
matter where the Queen goes we'll
guarantee that it protects the c5 Bishop
which is the only loose piece and blacks
position so even if black were to if
white were to play something like Queen
c2 rook takes d5 is perfectly acceptable
but Queen c1 and black is left crushed
so even if black tries this right now
we're going to take and play a bish b6
so the rook has lost even worse material
losses than before so why I was able to
scoop up a pond I had a healthier pawn
structure and in the end converted his
advantage with his strong and game
technique but yeah so he's kind of well
known for this Queen c1 move
strong and game's opening theory that
beautiful immortal game that he played
you